did you not ever think like looking out
on this like essex lad 20 year old just
calling these people in italy vice
presidents and that who they think i am
you know i ever have that did you have
to deal with that i still get it today
to be fair i don't think you ever lose
that there's always that sense of you
know i am only in my 20s i've not got
some crazy degree behind me you know how
do you overcome that then or not let
that like block your performance or hold
you back i said to my consultants today
is i think like if i put a vice
president candidate in front of you and
i asked you to qualify them as a
candidate you would have no issues with
it you would take the call you would
have a very good call you'd come away
with really good information you'd build
a really good credibility because you're
looking at them as a candidate there's
absolutely no difference if you approach
them as a decision-maker they're still
the exact same person all you have to do
is rather than asking them questions
around why they want a new job you've
just got to make yourself sound relevant
as to what are you looking for in your
new hiring strategy and you just have to
be confident that you can offer a
solution to that
[Music]
i